andreas est à cannes y kif l'hôtel et
comme vous l'avez vous avez eu des
nouvelles et on a grillé un mail à
londres à connecter sur les réseaux
jj relation avec quel os plus qu'à être
plus visible il ya brad pitt dicaprio en
ce moment à cannes là bien sûr j'ai au
bruit que deux mois web et vous ni moi
je préfère moi je préfère andreas alors
que je les lis aussi il a calé sur place
il a pu croiser beaucoup de people
beaucoup de fans mais aussi surtout
beaucoup de mythos regarde sur la
croisette on s'est rendu compte qu'il
suffisait de porter des robes de soirée
pour être une star
bonjour vous voulez vous les connaissez
vous savez qui c'est pourquoi vous les
prenez en photo du coup je ne sais pas
du coup on a voulu le vérifier
et pour l'occasion on habille et deux
amis à nous en robe de soirée on leur a
attribué deux faux gardes du corps et
trois fans hystériques
elles sont désormais jenna et millas
cote de grandes actrices américaines
venues présenter leurs films sur la
croisette
et comme prévu la rumeur s'est répandue
[Musique]
puis on s'est mis à crier leur nombre
mais bien sûr les actrices américaines
hilary ware vous les avez reconnus
oui oui c'est scott puisque les actrices
américaine jenna et mila scott c'est
vrai qu'est ce que ça fait de voir en
vrai écoutez c'est un plaisir elle est
aussi belle qu'en nature au cinéma est
ce que ça fait de les voir en vrai
rien du tout mais reconnaissez madame à
écouter absolument je trouve magnifique
splendide
elle présente un film aujourd'hui the
big tard car tout le monde en parle nous
inventons oui vous allez voir vous
connaissez quelqu'un qu'il a dit à une
amie
comment lutter à superbe absolument j'y
vais j'ai trouvé qu'elle a un talent
incroyable et remarques à wazemmes
rosereau aime écouter ses j'ai des
frissons et immortalisé avec des photos
c'est vraiment quelque chose excepté ce
qu'on pensait de sa liaison luxe et
vilaine a bien écouté savent s'est fait
discret mais je pense que c'est un beau
couple ans
[Musique]